it's crazy what's going on in australia
you see what's going on in australia
with the lockdowns
no
so uh
the amount of insanity that's directed
my way over this is la it's it's
hilarious uh i i got i get like text
messages from people like yo what's
going on like people are talking about
you and i was like i tweeted that the
quarantine camps were i was hyperbolic i
said concentration camp in a tweet and
all of a sudden they're screaming at the
top of their lungs and so someone
tweeted
a video of the minister of the i believe
it's the northeast territories in
australia i don't know a lot about
australia
but their politics government states and
or whatever they call them provinces or
states i think they're states but he
basically said
that you know i'd like to thank the adf
which is the australian military the
australian defense force for helping
transport suspected coveted cases and
close contacts to the howard springs
facility
he also said in that statement
that they're removing the five reasons
for leaving your home
the five reasons were exercise work
medical reasons getting food or you know
if you order something and he's like
this means they no longer have the five
reasons and they can only leave for
emergency medical procedures
to put it mildly if you live in these
areas they have announced you can't
leave your home to eat
then they say they're transporting these
people to the howard springs quarantine
facility which i guess is the first i
believe where they've been relocating
internal australians to these quarantine
camps
and then all of a sudden on twitter the
whole narrative becomes is it voluntary
and all these australian personalities
are either saying tim's a conspiracy
theorist because i quoted it's literally
in the guardians the guardian article
wrote this or they're like well tim to
be fair there's no evidence it's forced
and i was like
let me illustrate
you send to the military you tell them
to their faces you can't leave your home
to eat
and then you say but if you'd like to
voluntarily come with us to a quarantine
facility we'll give you food that's not
force
there's no scenario in which they are
not forcefully relocating indigenous
people and these are people who don't
even have coven they're close contacts
there's numerous stories about people
desperately trying to escape the
quarantine facilities one woman set fire
to a room forcing an evacuation one
woman jumped a fence and like ran off
and got caught and then fined five
thousand dollars so does that seem
people are too happy to be there yeah
there's also crazy footage of police
officers and security guards running up
to people because someone dared to put
one foot outside of their perimeter zone
that they were allowed to be in outside
of their holding cells i mean
there's also allegations of forced
vaccination by some of the indigenous
people in australia there's also record
waves of protests hitting the streets of
sydney hitting the streets of melbourne
i mean some of the videos and it's it's
so crazy that we're not even hearing
anything about this mass movement this
mass awakening of hundreds of thousands
of people hitting the streets not just
in italy not just in melbourne but in
guadalupe as well there's so many places
around the world that just are saying
hey we believe in natural rights we
believe in human rights you shouldn't be
taking this away from us in the name of
this emergency and
still there's there's not really a
mention of this which is absolutely
mind-boggling for me personally to say
the least i think lockdowns are coming
yeah for a lot of reasons we're seeing
it europe
uh australia just implemented another
lockdown they were like we're easing
lockdowns i'm like oh no omicron got
here omicron got here and people are
like how did omicron get into australia
if you can't enter unless you're
vaccinated and you can't even leave
unless you're vaccinated well it's
because omicron apparently is a variant
is less likely to be stopped by the
vaccine i suppose so
sounds like everything australia is
doing isn't stopping anything
they're going nuts with it yeah in the
u.s
i think we'll follow europe suit you
know your europe's uh what europe is
doing all these different you know
european countries i think that the
united states is there you're going to
see more and more blue states come up
with excuses why they need to reinstate
the lockdowns bring it all back and
conveniently right around
an election year midterm elections are
gonna be very important and they're
gonna do everything in their power in my
opinion to try and
fortify the election to put it mildly
well israel and japan just closed their
borders to all foreign visitors um
israel also just announced that they're
using their intelligence agencies to
have temporary permission to gain
access into the phone data of people who
were in the countries with confirmed
omnicron variant cases so again there's
nothing temporary about these new
laws and rules that they're implementing
but for them to use the national
security state israeli intelligence
agencies to hunt down and to contact
trace people who
were in a country with cases in the name
of security is is just absolutely
mind-boggling and the opposite of
security in my opinion you see ryan
long's sketch about being pro pro pfizer
he was like my pronouns are fuzzy what
do you say fizzy or
or whatever i thought that was really
good but he basically walks around he
talks about how he's like it's a skit
he's like i used to be a leftist and i
was you know against all the big pharma
and of course i don't like martin
shkreli but pfizer is different oh yeah
i got the pfizer vaccine and he walks up
to a guy and this is interesting um the
first thing i always say about this
stuff is like look i get it you know if
you go talk to your doctor figure out
what makes sense for you
we're not here to give you advice on
that stuff but in this ryan long video
he walks up to a random guy in the
street and he's like are you a pfizer
guy and the guy's like oh yeah he's like
i got all three man i'm in for three and
he and then and then ryan's like oh yeah
you're gonna go four and five he goes
i'm gonna do all of them
and i'm just like
wow
yeah
and those are average day
people just saying yes i'm gonna comply
uh meanwhile um south africa is also
reporting no major uptick in cases
they're reporting mild cases the
scientists who discovered this new
variant publicly came out and talked to
the bbc and said people are panicking
unnecessarily so
we still don't know what's going on here
again i'm not a medical doctor i'm not a
medical professional we're not here
giving you medical advice but i think
it's fair to say that we're in a
position where we don't know what's
happening and i think we shouldn't be
jumping to conclusions or spreading fear
at the same time which doesn't help
anyone stresses people out and actually
lower that system actually people can uh
i don't know if somebody wants to look
up someone super chatted that dan
bongino had got a breakthrough case of
kovit because he's vaccinated and that
he took the rogan cocktail oh
that's right yeah it's crazy to me
that i can have a doctor
say
go to sleep and sleep it off
and then me be like i would like a
second opinion and then call another
doctor says let's give you the full run
and then the media be like tim's dumb
for listening to his doctor i'm like
what was i supposed to do no doc this is
what i tweeted i was like my doctor says
i should take you know this medicine but
don lemon says it's a bad idea and of
course don lemon knows better than my
doctor yeah that's that's the reality
we're supposed to be living in yeah cnn
can't do wrong they're they're you know
holy and everyone should listen to them
and they should all be recommended to
everyone's youtube searches and you know
they're so innocent and loving
daily daily beast wrote an article that
said tim pool is a new poster boy for
ivermecton and the reason they chose
that headline is specifically because i
have not promoted it and actually talked
about how i told my doctor i didn't want
it and that i i was like i feel better i
don't want to take it and they
instructed me you have to like we're
prescribing this you should do it and i
was like i don't want it and i ended up
taking it anyway but they say poster boy
because if they said i promoted it or
was chilling for anything like that
that'd be a false statement effect
poster boy is a meaningless opinion
statement that can't be deciphered
properly you know what they're trying to
claim they're trying to make it seem
like i'm out there like i went on joe
rogan's show and i actually still argued
with him about it not like a strong
argument because i'm not a doctor and i
really don't know but i was just like i
don't know man i think i think this
stuff's challenging when you've got
political sides and they're making
arguments about stuff some people just
want to believe it works some people
don't want to believe it works and i
think it's fair to say there are some
studies that are very positive there are
some aggregate studies that are you know
um indeterminate but really just comes
down to what your doctor offers you so
for me it's like if my attitude is
slightly towards the negative like
you know people say they don't approve
it because um they don't make money off
it
and i'm like
if merck manufactures this stuff sure
they can make more money on the
proprietary but they could easily get
emergency use authorization for this if
they wanted to
so maybe there's a profit incentive or
something i don't know
but if i call a doctor and the doctor is
like we're giving you you know zabo dean
or something i'm not gonna be like whoa
whoa doc like i don't know that word
sounds weird i just be like okay i'll
look into it and you know we'll see if
it makes sense for me and then if when
it comes to ivermectin i know a little
bit more about it i was like the
monoclonal antibodies did me right and i
feel i feel totally fine and they were
like no we prescribed it for you and i
said okay doc whatever you say yeah
isn't that the attitude the left says
you're supposed to have like the
establishment left trust your doctor
trust the science but when i literally
do that they write smear articles about
me
and and i wish this wasn't so political
i mean even the naming of this variant
has been political it's it's it's the
world health organization skipping the
greek alphabet in order to appease
someone with a similar name z
uh what yeah they skipped that one yeah
so the anikara variant should have been
called the z variant but
but the world health organization
skipped it oh we're calling it the she
variant yeah
yeah so so again when you have such
politicization when you have so many
people uh benefiting off of this you
should be able to ask questions you
should be able to have an open
discussion and we can't and a lot of the
discussion is being hindered a lot of
the conversation is being stopped a lot
of the debate a lot of scientists are
even being hindered and that's
absolutely a nonsensical start in many
people's minds and if you want to
convince them you want to win hearts and
minds start with an open honest
conversation we don't even have that
let's call it the you know
we have we have the lemon variant yes
well uh the next one will be who should
get it next seltzer or cuomo the cuomo
variant yeah cooper the cooper variant
yeah
just all of cnn no excuse me the
vanderbilt variant
yeah why is his name anderson cooper is
because his mom didn't change her name
or what um i have no idea i didn't i i
didn't really do that much research into
it but uh he was raised by the
vanderbilts and uh also attended a very
interesting
after-school program in college let's
just double down on it because they
tried skipping over the she variant
we'll call it the xi jinping variant
yeah i like that that's good we'll just
literally name it after him yes well no
it's not a compromise it's just doubling
down like oh you want to not say she
will add the jinping to it just to go
straight for it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time